these are later shots that we can bring
you from South Oxfordshire this is
chrome art Gifford this is south
oxfordshire district council's
headquarters and this is the effects of
a suspected arson attack that took place
last night witnesses reported seeing a
car being driven into the central Lobby
you can see of this building loud
explosions then heard by local residents
they said it sounded like a bomb going
off yeah it's the latter stages of the
operation to damp down the thigh we're
looking at there these are pictures from
about an hour ago when the helicopter
was above the scene at its height there
were more than 100 firefighters there
and getting on for 30